oh hey my name is Benjamin LOI I'm a
professional photographer this year
Apple gave me a iPhone 7 plus before its
public release to test out and we walked
around the streets of New York
photographing this new tool great pro of
the new iPhone 7 plus the telephoto lens
this is something that gives you just a
reach it's something more than the
iPhone ever had before and a lot of
people who just love it for street
photography for photos of your kids or
photos of events we're a little bit far
away and you don't want to use that
digital zoom this makes a huge
difference it's battery life lasts
longer interestingly enough though it
takes longer to charge at least that's
what we found with portable battery
packs and that's probably something that
will change with firmware updates
another pro of the iPhone 7 plus massive
hard drive of 256 gigs you can put all
your music all your photos all your
movies there are a couple editing poems
that I love that I can really find my
voice in my vision within that and you
can do all here without going into your
computer without going at home I mean my
train ride home is usually spent editing
the pictures that I shot on my iPhone
so with any new device that comes out
has some growing pains some things that
need to be changed with the first
firmware patch and we can definitely say
that there were some issues that were
readily apparent and we're very
frustrating one was the way it started
underexposing and totally changing the
curves of highlights making a pink or
brown that was a bit frustrating another
of the cons was actually zooming the
camera by accident which is what ends up
happening when you're trying to change
the actual exposure slider it they're
too close together where you would zoom
the camera all of a sudden while you're
just trying to change your exposure but
that's something that definitely needs
to be dressed my big thing when I shoot
street photography what interests me the
most yes is the streak but it's also
especially in the urban environment love
light I love light I love light and
color the way it bounces off things and
weights fold in glass of all these
buildings and that's what I'm looking
for it people moving through that I mean
I want to just feel the way nature
interaction the urban environment for me
using maps on its best way to do that a
tool like this you're keeping both eyes
open as you shoot and you're not
blocking your face and that's a big
field I can keep on looking at you
looking at my subject looking
environment both my eyes open remain I
contact the intimacy with your subject
that's a big deal with this but you
can't do when you have a traditional
camera so here's the thing is this the
game-changing iPhone that we've all been
waiting for
probably not every single step of every
single generation of these tools gives
us something is something that we use
something that we adapt to and make our
images in this case as a photographer in
a different or better way
having the two lenses having a different
focal name will make a difference with
the type of imagery produced now instead
of having a digital zoom
[Music]